dernier jour de classe ce vendredi avant
la fermeture des écoles collèges et
lycées après les annonces des manuels
macron mercredi soir il faudra alors
patienter quatre semaines pour les
élèves avant de regagner leurs classes
une fermeture des écoles souhaité et
attendu pour certains français
effectivement les foyers dans les écoles
ça va très vite et ça peut se
démultiplier une vitesse énorme donc bon
bah toute façon il faut essayer
après sincèrement je pense que voilà au
point où on en est venu faudrait
peut-être arriver à faire un confinement
total pendant des semaines et des
semaines pour éradiquer en fait ce virus
qui est en train de nous pourrir la vie
d'agent touffu ses besoins des jeunes
vaches étudiante
du coup on en a marre et en plus de cela
on peut ne plus travailler on n'a pas de
vacances n'a rien aucun protéger les
jeunes et protéger les plus les plus
anciens à qui on pense pas vraiment pour
l'union nationale des syndicats
autonomes la fermeture des
établissements scolaires était
indispensable à condition toutefois de
lancer un plan de vaccination pour les
enseignants la dégradation rapide de ces
derniers jours et de ces dernières
semaines rendait le système on va dire
hors contrôle de fonctionnement normal
pour c'étaient des mesures qui était
attendu et qui sont des mesures qui sont
satisfaisantes
après il y à un horizon qui est posée la
difficulté d'approvisionnement en dose
donne toute visite
édité néanmoins le gouvernement doit se
mettre en capacité de prévoir un
concurrent programmé deux vaccination
pour les personnels pour arriver en fait
dans les meilleures conditions pour que
les écoles les établissements ouvrent le
plus rapidement possible et dans les
meilleures conditions
un troisième confinement nationale une
fois de plus allégée des déplacements
interrégionaux proscrit un couvre-feu à
19h maintenu et une fermeture des écoles
pour quatre semaines
les français vont devoir une fois de
plus s'adapter aux mesures annoncées par
le chef de l'état dans les rues de la
capitale
l'annnonce de ces nouvelles restrictions
ne semble pas surprendre les français
oui je pense que tu as oms étaient
nécessaires pour que l'on puisse avancer
plus vite et puis y avait des tensions
et des mesures à prendre pour que ce
soit plus restrictif
moi je pense que c'est pas assez il
faudrait être plus ferme et fermer deux
fois pour toute et mais ça on aurait dû
les faire qu'on veut c'est moins beau
parce que là ça devient beaucoup plus
difficile de rester à la maison pour
cette fois ci je suis assez d'accord
je suis même totalement d'accord c'est
ce que j'aurais fait je suis pas
président républicain mais je pense que
c'est exactement ce que j'aurais fait il
alla cette fois ci c'est très bien je
pense que ça a été fait un peu trop tard
après s'ils font passer par là j'ai
envie de dire oui pourquoi pas moi
j'aurais été plus pour un confinement un
peu plus strictes déjà il ya un mois ou
deux
les mesures annoncées prendront effet ce
samedi soir et ce pour quatre semaines
de quoi laisser du temps et un répit au
gouvernement qui mise plus que jamais
sur une arrivée massive de vaccins pour
retrouver peut-être un semblant de vie
normale